When we first studied glycolysis,
we saw that if we started with a glucose molecule
and the process has gone -
glucose, which contains six carbon atoms,
there are also oxygen and water atoms,
but it's six-carbon sugar.
This six-carbon sugar
is divided into two pyruvate molecules, each of which has three carbon atoms.
We produce net in this process
two molecules of ATP.
We invest two ATP molecules in the first phase,
then produce four ATP molecules.
We generally win two ATF molecules.
But this is not the only thing that happens.
We also have two molecules NAD -
nicotinamidadendinucleotide.
NAD is reduced to NAD.
Why is it reduced?
Here we see that NAD has a positive charge,
but becomes a neutral molecule when it receives electrons.
Here it is reduced.
Your next question may be,
"What happens next?".
If this process takes place in me or in you,
if we have enough oxygen,
we will continue with cellular respiration.
The processes will be transferred to the mitochondria,
because molecules pyruvate and NADN can be
used to drive more ATPs.
Pyruvate continues to degrade
in the Krebs cycle, also known as the citric acid cycle.
In this porcelain is produced ATP and NADN.
NAM can participate
in the electron transport chain,
resulting in the production of even more ATP.
But if we are in a situation,
where we do not have oxygen
or if we are an organism,
who does not like to use oxygen
or does not know how to use it, what happens then?
This is what we will be talking about in this video.
This is one of the possible paths.
This is the lactic acid fermentation.
It is one of the two main types of fermentation.
Lactic acid fermentation.
In lactic acid fermentation, the main goal is not
to produce more ATPs and yes
recycle pyruvate and NADH.
Although pyruvate and NADN
have free energy that can turn into ATP,
if we have lactic acid fermentation,
we give up this energy.
In fact, we will use pyruvate,
to oxidize NAD
to +.
Thus, we get even more + so that glycolysis can flow again.
Organisms in which fermentation takes place
use glycolysis as a major source of energy.
As we have said, the purpose of fermentation is recycling
of what is considered waste in this case - the NADN,
to get over +
and allow glycolysis to flow again.
Now you can say, "Oh, that's probably a strange thing,
which is not common in living nature. "
But actually maybe every day or every week
you consume organisms that
perform lactic-acidic fermentation.
Here's a picture of yogurt.
We get yogurt when
certain types of lactobacilli digest sugars in milk.
They do glycolysis
and then passed to lactic acid fermentation,
turning pyruvate into lactate.
Or if we look at the acids -
lactic acid or pyruvic acid.
Pyruvate is the major part of pyruvic acid.
A lactate - the lactic acid.
It is what gives yogurt
its unique taste.
This bacterium here -
lactobacilli.
This is only one type of lactobacilli.
There are different types
everyone involved in the production of these foods.
But this one is for yogurt.
If you like Korean food, here is kimchi,
it uses another type of lactobacilli
and also lactic-acidic fermentation
of sugars in vegetables.
This here is sour cabbage,
we have another type of lactobacilli,
which performs lactic-acidic fermentation
of cabbage sugars.
So we get sour cabbage.
-
Think about the processes that are going on.
As I said, we have
pyruvate or pyruvic acid (pyruvic acid).
What I drew here
is pyruvic acid,
-
because we have a hydrogen proton.
If we lose the hydrogen proton,
it's the same thing painted again,
but without the hydrogen proton.
This oxygen kept this electron.
All other hydrogen atoms
are implied.
The three hydrogen atoms
this carbon atom is implied.
Here I paint the same thing with a different recording.
Here we have lost the proton
and we will call this compound pyruvate.
They're drinking.
Pyruvate acid or
pyruvate
are used for NADH oxidation.
They take their hydride anion, they take an electron,
actually take more than one electron,
overall NAD loses electrons.
If he loses electrons,
it is oxidized.
Thus, NAD + can be used again in glycolysis.
When the pyruvic acid interacts with NADH,
it is reduced.
It is reduced,
receives electrons.
If we think of the acid,
it will turn into this here - lactic acid.
Milk
acid.
Lactic acid.
That is why we call the process of lactic acid fermentation,
because we take pyruvate -
if we had oxygen, or if the body knew how to use it,
perhaps the process would continue
to cell breathing and to use this energy.
But with lactic acid fermentation,
we use pyruvate to oxidize NAD
and get even more +.
Let's look at what exactly
happens.
The first thing I want to show you,
because very often in biology classes
learns about NAD and NADN,
but it looks like a very abstract molecule.
This is a drawing of the molecule.
This is nicotinamidadendinucleotide.
A long name,
but when we divide it into parts, we can understand what it means.
-
This is where it comes from
nicotinamide.
This is our good friend Aden.
We see it in the ATF,
as well as one of the nitrogen bases in DNA and RNA.
Here we have ribose.
-
We have a phosphate group.
Thus, nicotinamide, adenine,
we have a nucleotide here
we also have another nucleotide.
Thus we get nicotinamidadendinucleotide.
So the name is very logical.
I wanted to show it visually,
To Understand,
it's a pretty complex molecule.
Sometimes you only see the letters NAD
and you do not understand what the molecule really is.
It is coenzyme.
We learned about coenzymes in other videos.
The enzyme that catalyses this reaction is
lactic acid dehydrogenase.
Remember most
of the enzymes are large protein structures,
folded in different ways.
Then we have NAD.
In the case of lactic acid fermentation,
we have NADN,
this is NAD.
I draw roughly how NADH would look like.
The drawing is not accurate.
He will react with the feather.
-
Will react with pyruvate,
although the pyruvate
is officially considered
for the substrate of the enzyme,
the whole purpose of the process is to oxidize NAD.
NOD to lose a hydrogen proton and an additional electron.
So, a hydrogen proton, a hydrogen electron
and another electron.
Lose a hydride anion.
How does this happen?
It happens because nitrogen
there is an additional free e-pair
and this electron pair may form a double bond
right here.
If this carbon now has a double bond,
this carbon atom must be released from this double bond.
Therefore, this comes here.
This comes here.
And now, if we have a double connection here,
we see it in the final product,
this carbon atom will have to release one of its links.
He will free himself from the whole covalent bond
with this hydrogen atom of both electrons.
These two electrons will be released.
Those here.
Then these two electrons
can be linked to this carbon here.
Once this carbon atom forms a new covalent bond,
you have to get rid of one of your old ties.
That's why he's released
by one of its double bonds with this oxygen atom.
It can return to that oxygen
or find a hydrogen proton
by a passing water molecule or by a hydroxone ion.
I can draw this.
He can grab a hydrogen proton.
So, what do we get?
This e-pair is already here,
we have a double link here,
we have lost one of these hydrogen atoms,
obviously I have not painted all the water atoms
in these molecules.
So now we are back to NAD.
This nitrogen atom
was neutral,
but now he has not kept these two electrons for himself,
but it shares them,
therefore, will have a positive charge.
So we call the compound NAD +.
NAD has lost hydrogen and an electron,
Hydrogen proton, hydrogen electron and another electron.
Now there is a positive charge.
And pyruvate is now the compound,
which I drew here.
I display it deprotonated.
It's a lactate.
Lactate.
If we had a proton here,
it would be lactic acid.
I hope this video was interesting,
I find it very interesting
to understand how all these processes are going.
Lactobacilli are not the only organisms that use lactic acid fermentation,
but are useful for the most diverse
delicious foods we produce.
Remarkably,
that these
complex processes are running constantly
in the glory around us,
and sometimes in our own bodies,
as well as in these small organisms.
For example, this lactobacilli here
has a size between
five and ten micrometers.
Five micrometres are five millionth of a meter.